[Music]
probably the most challenging thing that
I've ever done as far as my favorite
career it's been concerns it really has
felt like 14 days of non-stop battle
against LeBron O's
and
today is Tuesday January 24th and the AI
is ahead by a bit over $700,000 in chips
it is a very large lead but we are
definitely not popping any champagne yet
because the humans are very crafty and
every day is a new day the AI Vistula
Broadus is quite a bit better than a
conical in 2015 it made some pretty
large mistakes at times you don't see
that with a broader it's much more
calculated and much more tough you
really have to pry every chip you can
out of LeBrons his hands and you have to
do it with skill not counting on his
mistake most surprising thing is its
ability to adjust its ability to just
learn everyday and get better it's been
taxing on us to try to find weaknesses
especially after it just seems to be
able to adjust to us and fix stuff you
don't often see play like librettist
where it's like 250% 500% all in for
like 2000 the middle abroad is all in
for nineteen thousand you know LeBron
has kind of worked out a good strategy
there and it's very tough to plug it
because librettist is the work of
millions of core hours on a super
computer playing trillions of hands of a
game of poker analyzing itself it
figured out the perfect way to do that I
think it's a really good step for for
for AI in general as it beats us right I
mean this is this is an incredibly
difficult game to solve that's a pretty
good step in the direction of artificial
intelligence for applications it's very
important because most real-world
applications where you have multiple
interacting parties are imperfect
information games things like
negotiation bargaining auctions cyber
security and if we are able to show that
the best AI has surpassed the quality of
the best treatments in strategic
thinking under imperfect information
that would have tremendous implications
you
[Music]